now that you look back on your career
and your hair at the stripper Awards
what do you believe you did wrong and
what do you believe you did right well I
did a lot of stuff wrong like every
writer the only thing I did right was I
you know stayed with it for a long time
and wrote through my mistakes and do you
have a certain time of day or night that
you before writing are you more paper in
the morning less so and never exuberant
but I write well in the morning and is
that your most prefer that time oh yeah
no it's a yeah that's a regular practice
is that something that you knew in the
winter - even at eight years to midnight
where you had a meal what time we fest
are you in what style weather is that a
title I learned that back in Graduate
story I've been writing like a college
student
late at night and at some point I've
tried writing early in the morning and I
just realized it was an entirely
different experience for me with that
you know sort of pressure from the day
you write a first Rock tales and a shaft
and then fill in there should we take
away as you as you were
or you the opposite end so I had a very
very tight outline in there I don't
outline but I tend to write underwrite
and revision process is usually adding
rather than big cuts fine storytelling I
lived through stories and I think most
people do so I think it's just one of
the you know human activities have a job
I would say it's better to do a little
bit every day than to try and binge
right so just fine you can find an hour
every day that might be a good way to
get some work done
where do you get your best ideas when
you drive it sleeping sleeping I wake up
I'm Stein okay yeah thank you very much
sir